This is LabeloxAV, a data engine for autonomous driving built
around Indian roads.
Everything you are about to see runs against a live database with 381 driving sessions, 42,766 frames and 598,179 labelled
objects in it.
No screen in this tour is a mock up.
Where a number is small or a page is empty, that is the real
state of the system and the narration will say so.
The product is ten platforms over a single data spine.
Annotation, review, measurement, governance, edge deployment and the rest each get their own surface, but they all read and
write the same sessions, frames, objects and tracks.
That is why a correction made in the editor changes what the
gate measures an hour later.
Work is scoped by project, and each project belongs to a
domain pack.
The autonomous driving pack brings the road ontology, the camera and LiDAR sensor model and the traffic scenario
vocabulary.
A second pack for physical security shares the same spine and
none of the road specific code.
Data arrives here.
The importer takes dashcam video, ROS bags, MCAP recordings and raw sensor drives, and turns each one into a session with
frames at a fixed timestamp.
For this tour I ingested four real recordings, of which three
are dashcam clips from the owner of this machine.
The last is a KITTI drive from Karlsruhe with a sixty four
beam LiDAR on the roof.
Most teams already have labels somewhere else.
The migration path reads COCO, YOLO, Pascal and CVAT exports, maps their class names onto this ontology, and records the
mapping so that nothing silently changes meaning.
Classes it cannot map are held back rather than guessed at.
Every ingested session lands in the inspector.
This is a Foxglove class viewer built into the product, so you can check a recording before you spend any labelling effort on
it.
The health gate at the top is the useful part.
It refuses a session with broken timestamps, missing calibration or a camera that dropped out, instead of letting
the problem reach the labellers.
This is the KITTI drive.
The timeline shows every topic on one clock, the camera
alongside the LiDAR and the GPS.
The panels are native, not an embedded iframe, so a click on the timeline moves the point cloud, the image and the ego pose
together.
Calibration is what makes three dimensional work possible.
This session carries real intrinsics from the KITTI rig, a focal length of seven hundred and twenty one pixels over a
twelve forty two by three seventy five image.
Without this the system can still draw boxes, but it cannot
tell you how far away anything is.
Here is the vehicle's own motion.
Speed, yaw rate and the trajectory it drove.
The KITTI import brought 154 measured ego poses from the GPS
and inertial unit.
Before this import the entire corpus had three satellite fixes across forty one thousand frames, which is the honest reason most of the three dimensional work here was estimated rather
than measured.
A dataset is a frozen selection of frames with a content hash.
Two people training on the same dataset identifier are training on exactly the same images and labels, which is the
only way a comparison between two models means anything.
Labelling starts automatically.
You choose a session and the classes you care about, and the
auto label runner works through it batch by batch.
Batch by batch is a deliberate constraint, not an
implementation detail.
The runner holds a GPU slot, checks free video memory between batches, and stops if a training job wants the card, so a
labelling run cannot take the machine down.
This is the annotation canvas with real machine predictions on
a real frame.
The tools run down the left side.
Box, polygon, segment anything, lane, drivable area,
keypoints, amodal extent and depth.
Every tool is registered in one place, so the keyboard shortcut you see in the panel is the shortcut that actually
fires.
The describe tool is the one worth stopping on.
You type what you want in plain words, for example a cow standing on the median, and an open vocabulary detector
proposes it with a segment anything mask.
This exists because the ontology will never have a word for everything on an Indian road, and the alternative is that
those objects go unlabelled forever.
Lanes and drivable surface are annotated as geometry rather
than boxes.
The drivable mask now covers ninety nine point nine percent of
frames in the corpus.
It used to cover under four percent, and the gap was not a
model problem.
Three separate consumers were reading the masks in a format
nobody had written.
Attributes are swept across many objects at once instead of
one at a time.
Occlusion level, truncation, whether a rider is wearing a
helmet, whether a vehicle is parked or moving.
One pass over a hundred crops of the same class is far faster than a hundred visits to the editor, and it keeps the
judgement consistent.
Road furniture gets its own surface.
Signs, signals, poles, barriers and markings.
Signs carry an IRC sixty seven code, which is the Indian standard, so a mandatory sign and a cautionary sign are
distinguishable without reading the pictogram.
Behind the auto labelling sits an ensemble.
Several detectors run over the same frame and their outputs
are reconciled.
Where they agree the label is cheap and probably right.
Where they disagree is exactly where a human should be looking, and that disagreement is mined rather than averaged
away.
Agreement between models becomes pseudo ground truth for
training.
One lesson from building this is recorded on the page.
Choosing the teacher pair by how many predictions each model
made gave nine consensus labels.
Choosing by how many frames the two models shared gave one
thousand one hundred and ninety.
Machine labels are proposals until a person rules on them.
The queue orders work by how much a verdict is worth, combining model uncertainty, class rarity and whether a gate
is currently blocked on that class.
There are 528,793 objects waiting in review right now, which
tells you honestly how far ahead of the humans the machine is.
Grid review shows many crops of one class at once.
The eye is very good at spotting the odd one out in a wall of similar images, and very bad at staying calibrated across a
thousand single decisions.
Accept or reject applies to everything selected in one
keystroke.
Rapid review is the keyboard only mode for a long session.
One crop, one key, next crop.
It records how long each verdict took, because the cost of a label in minutes is the number the whole economics of this
system rests on.
This is the full annotation table, filterable by class, state,
source, session and reviewer.
State is the important column.
A label is in review, auto accepted, settled or accepted, and
accepted means a person ruled on it.
The machine can never write accepted.
That is enforced in code and there is a test that fails the
build if any code path tries.
Any single label opens to its full history.
Which model proposed it, at what confidence, which human touched it and when, what it was before each change, and which
training run consumed it.
You can answer where did this label come from for any of
598,179 objects.
Quality is measured, not asserted.
Precision comes from stratified samples with Wilson confidence intervals, so a class with twelve judged crops reports a wide
interval rather than a confident number.
Unmeasured is reported as unmeasured.
It is never reported as zero and never as fine.
Errors are typed rather than counted.
A missed detection, a duplicate, a class confusion and a loose box are four different problems with four different fixes, and lumping them into one accuracy number hides which one you
actually have.
This page measures the reviewers.
Control samples with a known answer are mixed into the queue, so agreement between people can be computed without anybody
re-reviewing anybody.
A finding worth admitting is here.
Thirty thousand eight hundred and sixty three of thirty thousand eight hundred and sixty five reviews carry no timing,
because the field was only wired up recently.
An object across frames is a track, and a track is the unit
that matters for driving.
The corpus holds 13,807 of them.
Eighty four percent of tracks used to blink out and restart as
a new identity.
Interpolation across gaps had been written but never run, and turning it on filled one hundred and thirty seven thousand
gaps.
Corrections apply to the track, not the frame.
Relabelling a motorcycle as a rider used to reach one frame out of ninety three, because the editor and the review queue
took different write paths.
They now share one, and the propagation is visible on this
timeline.
A vehicle with several cameras sees the same object more than
once.
With calibration, a box drawn in one view projects into every
other view in the rig, so you annotate once.
The corpus has six multi camera sessions, so the measured
benefit here is small and I will not inflate it.
Between two labelled frames the vehicle moved a known
distance.
That motion alone predicts where a static object should appear next, without running any model, and it is enough to carry a
label forward through a stretch of road.
When a track breaks behind a bus and reappears, the recovery pass tries to rejoin the two halves using appearance and
predicted position.
A rejoined track is marked as rejoined rather than silently
merged, because a wrong merge is worse than two short tracks.
This is where the tour gets its real LiDAR.
The KITTI drive brought 154 point clouds from a sixty four
beam Velodyne, about 18 million points.
Before this import the corpus had four hundred and fifty three thousand points in total, all of them estimated from single
camera depth rather than measured by a laser.
Cuboids are drawn in the point cloud with the camera image
beside them.
The ego trajectory runs underneath, so a box can be placed in
the world frame and stays put while the vehicle moves past it.
The linked view keeps the image and the cloud in step.
Click a two dimensional box and the matching three dimensional
box highlights, and the other way round.
This is also how the lifted boxes are checked.
A cuboid estimated from camera depth alone is compared against
the laser points that actually fall inside it.
Sessions on a map, by route and by city.
The locations here are aggregated into cells rather than drawn as raw points, and I will come back to why in the privacy
chapter.
Verdyx is where models are measured.
Accuracy is reported per class with an interval, and against a
frozen gold set that no training run is allowed to touch.
There are 15 registered models, each with its lineage
recorded.
What it was trained from, which teacher it distilled, and
which dataset hash it saw.
An average number hides the cases that matter.
Performance is sliced by night, rain, occlusion and by the
safety critical classes.
Frames are also perturbed on purpose.
Occlusion, dusk, rain, fog and motion blur are applied to real
images and the model is re-scored.
The current champion loses twenty four points of motorcycle recall under occlusion, which is the kind of thing an average
accuracy score will never tell you.
A scorecard is the summary a person actually reads before a
release.
Per class recall and precision, the slices that regressed, the
gate result and the reason if it was blocked.
It is generated from the measurement run, so it cannot drift
from the evidence.
Training runs are scheduled here and they are the only thing
allowed to hold the GPU for a long time.
Everything else in the system checks whether training holds
the card before it asks for it, and backs off if it does.
That single rule is why labelling, embedding, depth and three dimensional lifting can all run on one desktop without
fighting each other.
Lineage connects a deployed model back to every label it
learned from.
If a label is found to be wrong, this answers which models saw
it, and therefore which measurements are now suspect.
Events are the moments worth finding.
Hard braking, a cut in, a near miss, a pedestrian crossing
against the signal.
They are detected from ego dynamics and object tracks
together.
An honest caveat from building this.
The dynamics signal in this corpus is noisier than the events it is being asked to find, so the detector is tuned to over
report and let a human cut.
Events are searchable by description, so you can ask for every time a rider overtook on the left while the vehicle was
braking, and get frames rather than a report.
This is the part I would show a sceptic first.
The system proposes its own work, but it cannot approve
itself.
Every autonomous action is a proposal with evidence, a named rule that fired, and a revert button that actually undoes the
writes.
A class is signed off by sequential testing rather than a
fixed sample.
A clean class proves itself in far fewer verdicts and a bad
one fails in a handful.
Accept is deliberately conjunctive.
The sequential test and the confidence interval must both agree before anything is accepted, while a rejection is allowed to fire early, because rejecting early is the safe
direction to be wrong in.
The agent layer plans labelling work, criticises its own
output and reconciles conflicts.
It works in chunks, and every chunk is one recorded run with
the exact rows it wrote.
Reverting a run is a real database operation, not a flag.
Governance sits above all of it.
There is one killswitch that stops every autonomous writer,
and every automated path checks it before doing anything.
Approval thresholds are set per action here, so a team can let the system merge duplicate tracks on its own while still
requiring a human for an ontology change.
Every long running piece of work is a job with a state, a
progress figure and a log.
Jobs that die are reaped rather than left claiming to run,
which sounds obvious and took a real bug to get right.
One chronological record of everything that changed, by
machine or by person.
This is what you read when a number moved and nobody knows
why.
The reasoner explains a decision in words, with the evidence
attached.
Why this class was blocked, why this lot was rejected, why
this model did not promote.
The words are generated from the same fields the gate read, so an explanation cannot flatter a decision that the evidence
does not support.
The data engine is the loop that decides what to label next.
More data is not better data.
The question is always which thousand frames would move the
number that is currently stuck.
Frames are embedded as vectors, 42,088 of them, so you can
search the corpus by resemblance rather than by keyword.
Show me more scenes like this one is a query the system can
answer directly.
Text search runs over classes, attributes, sessions and scenario descriptions, and combines with the vector search, so a natural request narrows to a set of frames you can send
straight to a labelling job.
Discovery looks for what the ontology has no word for.
Clusters of frames that no class explains well are surfaced as
candidates for a new class.
This is how an Indian road corpus grows a vocabulary that a
western ontology never had.
Sievyx filters.
Near duplicate frames, frames that are almost all sky, frames
the camera auto exposure ruined.
Removing these before labelling is the cheapest quality improvement available, because a duplicate frame costs a full
label and teaches nothing.
The long tail is the whole problem in India.
Cattle on the carriageway, three people on one motorcycle, an
auto rickshaw reversing, a hand cart at night.
These classes are rare in any corpus and over represented in the situations that matter, and this page ranks them by how
starved each one is.
This closes the loop.
A blocked gate produces a recall deficit per class, the deficit builds its own review batch, the batch produces
labels, the labels retrain the model and the gate runs again.
That loop cleared a class that had been stuck at zero point
one four recall for five training cycles.
A campaign is a labelling goal with a budget and a deadline.
The system allocates it against the marginal value of a label per rupee, using the measured time a verdict actually takes
rather than an assumed rate.
Interesting moments are exported as OpenSCENARIO files, so a situation found in real footage becomes a test case a
simulator can replay.
Where the esmini simulator is installed, each exported scenario is replayed at export time and the bundle records
whether it was actually valid.
Corpus level analytics.
Class balance, geographic coverage, time of day, weather, how
much of each session is labelled.
One number here is uncomfortable and deliberately left
visible.
Of 598,179 objects, 788 carry a human verdict.
The machine has run far ahead of the people, and pretending otherwise would make every quality number on this tour
meaningless.
A dataset is built from a query rather than a folder.
All night time frames containing a rider without a helmet,
excluding the gold set, excluding synthetic frames.
The result is frozen with a hash and a datasheet that states
exactly what went in.
Synthetic frames exist, built by pasting real instances of
starved classes into real backgrounds.
They are quarantined structurally rather than by a filter.
A synthetic label carries its own state and its own source, so every reader that measures anything excludes them without
having to remember to.
No synthetic pixel can reach a validation split or a gold set.
Indian data protection law applies to road footage, because
faces and number plates are personal data.
Faces and plates are detected and redacted, and the redaction is verified by re-running detection on the redacted image
rather than trusting that the blur was applied.
Access to unredacted imagery is a role, every access is logged
with a reason, and the log is not deletable from the product.
Aggregated releases carry a differential privacy budget.
Counts are noised, map cells with fewer than ten sessions are suppressed entirely, and when the budget for a scope is spent the endpoint refuses rather than quietly returning a weaker
guarantee.
The same spine runs a physical security pack.
Cameras, zones, incidents.
It shares ingest, annotation, review, measurement and
governance, and shares none of the road specific code.
An import contract is enforced in the build so that the core
can never reach into a pack.
Incidents in the security pack are assembled from tracks and
zones.
There is no transcription anywhere in this pack.
No text is read off a frame and no text content is stored, which is a deliberate scope limit rather than a missing
feature.
Exports go out in the formats teams already use.
COCO, YOLO, KITTI, nuScenes, OpenLABEL and the scenario
formats.
Every bundle carries a datasheet with the query that built it, the class counts, the synthetic share and the privacy
parameters.
Forgyx takes a trained model to the edge.
Export, quantise to eight bit, compile for the target and
benchmark it.
A model that is accurate and too slow has not solved the
problem, so latency is a gate condition and not a footnote.
Deployment is staged.
A candidate runs in shadow beside the current model on the
vehicle before it takes over anything.
The distillation loop here trains a small student from a large teacher and repeats until it fits the latency budget, or stops
after four rounds and reports that it could not.
Deployed models report back.
Latency, thermal state, frames dropped and where the model was
uncertain.
Uncertain frames come home and re-enter the labelling queue,
which is the outer loop of the whole data engine.
Sanyx watches the hardware.
Device temperature, storage, camera health and clock drift
across the fleet.
Predicted failures ahead of time.
A camera whose focus is slowly drifting or a drive filling up.
A vehicle that records unusable footage for a week is more expensive than one that stops, because nobody notices until
the labelling starts.
Operations shows the system's own health.
Queue depths, GPU memory, worker state and the killswitch.
The resource rules here are the reason this whole tour runs on
one desktop.
Every heavy path takes a slot, works in batches, checks free
memory between them and yields to training.
Several people work the same corpus at once, with assignment,
locking and comment threads on individual objects.
The interface is translated into Hindi, Kannada and Tamil, because the people doing the labelling are frequently not
working in English.
Each person sees their own throughput, their agreement with
control samples and their history.
Measured, not estimated, and visible to the person it
describes.
That is the full system.
What is real today is the ingest, the auto labelling, the review surfaces, the tracking, the measurement with honest
intervals, the governance and the export path.
What is thin today is human verdicts, with 788 of 598,179 objects ruled on, and measured ego pose, where the 154 poses
from this KITTI import are the first the corpus has ever had.
Both of those are visible on the pages you just saw, because a
data engine that hides its own gaps is not a data engine.
It is a demo.